[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos a mais uma live da
nossa comunidade fechada do YouTube.
Boa noite, Josiane, seja muito bem-vinda
ao nosso grupo. Boa noite
Caridade Alves, Alessandra
Chead,
Elisa,
Eliana,
Cleid Van e Célia
também. Seja bem-vinda, Enilde.
Vamos às perguntas de hoje. Temos 22
perguntas para responder hoje. Deixa eu
só começar a apresentação.
Vocês estão me ouvindo bem?
Boa noite, Maria Amélia, Leila Cristina.
Só me confirmem se vocês estão me
escutando, tá?
Aqui
áudio excelente. Obrigado pela
informação, Cristina.
Boa noite, corretor Ângelo.
Boa noite, Joel. Obrigado por ter
respondido. Obrigado pela resposta,
Cleidivan.
Ótimo. Vamos lá.
Doutor, mais uma vez parabéns pelo seu
trabalho. Muita admiração por você
realmente ajudar na saúde e bem-estar
das pessoas. Muito obrigado pela pelo
carinho aí, Ângelo. Gostaria de saber se
podemos tomar vários antioxidantes
juntos. NC, alho negro, curina, as
taxantina.
pensando em longevidade, desempenho
físico ou se o uso desses suplementos
pode ser contínuo ou em ciclos.
É uma pergunta muito boa e nem sempre é
fácil de responder.
É totalmente viável você associar todos
esses suplementos, o nac, o alho negro,
cúrcuma, as tachantina. Não há
compatibilidade
problemática aí de você juntar todos
esses suplementos, tá bom? Eles
trabalham cinicamente, ou seja, um vai
ajudar o outro. Geralmente um
antioxidante ajuda que o outro
antioxidante não oxide, OK? Eles vão
trabalhar também em vias diferentes de
estresse oxidativo.
Por exemplo, a NACE, o NACE e a glicina,
eles vão ajudar a aumentar a produção de
glota. A cuccomina tem uma ação
antiinflamatória profunda, anticâncer,
também ajuda na resistência insulínica,
tem uma série de propriedades positivas,
é um dos mais estudados. A tachantina é
um dos mais poderosos aí antioxidantes
que vai proteger as membranas celulares
de uma maneira única. O óleo negro é
excelente paraa saúde arterial,
cardiovascular, porque tem compostos
organo sulfurados, né, que vão ajudar
nisso daí também vão ajudar no detox.
Então essa combinação que você tá
apresentando é uma combinação muito
interessante.
Dá para usar continuamente sim esses daí
que você falou aí. Eh, mas seria
interessante fazer uma reavaliação a
cada três ou seis meses, dependendo das
suas comorbidades.
Agora existe teoricamente, tá, a chance
de que se você utilizar muitos
antioxidantes por doses altas por um
tempo prolongado, que em excesso poderia
prejudicar adaptações benéficas, que é o
chamada fenômeno de ormese, são
adaptações benéficas, por exemplo, do
exercício físico. Então, por exemplo, se
seu foco for performance atlética ou se
foco for hipertrofia,
tem que pensar nisso daí, porque pode
atrapalhar a performance e hipertrofia.
Existe também aí estudos mostrando na
literatura que ciclos de 8 semanas
usando e duas semanas sem usar pode
funcionar bem para quem já tem uma boa
saúde mitocondrial. OK? Mas como eu
falei, pode ser utilizado continuamente,
sim, especialmente se você tiver sendo
monitorado.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Boa noite, Dr. Alan. O DMSO ajuda na
degeneração macular e outros tipos de
cegueira? Sim, o DMSO tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias importantes. É só a
questão da polêmica se pode ser
utilizado via oral ou se só pode ser
utilizado pela parte externa.
OK? Então, eh, o uso do MSO por via oral
é polêmico e não é recomendado
oficialmente, mas mu gente toma e não
tem problema com DMSO vioral, OK?
Quando nós falamos especificamente sobre
degeneração macular, que é o principal
causa de cegueira no idoso,
nós não temos assim grandes estudos, as
evidências são preliminares, são
limitadas,
tem grande potencial, mas a gente não
tem muitos dados ainda disponíveis para
essa questão da generação macular.
Então, o que que eu propria para
tratamentos mais consolidados para
degeneração macular seria a
fotobiomodulação,
que eu acho que isso vai crescer muito
nos próximos anos.
Suplementos como antioxidantes que podem
retardar a progressão própria taxantinas
e achantina luteína.
E paraa forma úmida, né, da
degeneração macular, nós temos aquelas
injeções que se faz na retina, né, que
são as injeções anti fator de
crescimento vascular, né, vascular
indutilal growth factor, que é o
antivef.
E sim, o demencial poderia ser utilizado
como quadjuvante pelo potencial
antiinflamatório,
mas não use como tratamento principal,
OK?
A próxima pergunta.
Vejo alguns influenciadores indicando as
suplementações da Always Fit oficial
Farma. Pela sua experiência são empresas
de qualidade e confiança?
Vamos lá. Então, essa Alis Fit eu não
conhecia. Eu vou fazer uma pesquisa para
saber, para poder responder.
Aparentemente ela tem um bom histórico
de reputação, pelo menos entre os
consumidores,
uma nota média de 8,7
a 9 no reclame aqui.
Então é uma empresa verificada pelo pelo
reclame. Aqui
agora tem que dizer a você o seguinte.
Ah,
Anvisa em maio 2025 suspendeu vários
lotes dos produtos por falta de
avaliação de segurança para uso
sublingual, tá? Então, a empresa
informou que já se adequou às
normativas, retirou menções ao uso
sublingual
e mantendo apenas produtos com indicação
oral. OK? Então, parece que é empresa de
boa índole e de boa fé, que se preocupou
em adaptar a regulação.
Afficial Farma, eu posso dizer para
vocês que eu já visitei esse pessoal
muitos anos atrás, a sede deles em
Diadema, aqui na Grande de São Paulo, na
região do ABC.
Mas a informação que eu tenho doicial
Farma é que eles têm essa prática de
ficar abrindo toda hora CNPJs novos,
porque eles têm a mania de vender sem
receita. E aí eles são pegos
e aí eles fecham o CNPJ, abram outro,
abrem outro, tá? Essa informação que eu
tenho. Pode ser que essa informação não
esteja muito
eh correta, digamos assim, mas eu
desconfiaria da Official Farma, tá? Toma
muito cuidado com o Farma. Eu visitei lá
a loja deles em Diadema, uma loja até
bonitinha, mas eu não fiz a visita
técnica lá dentro para ver a parte de
manipulação deles, tá?
Então eu tomaria muito cuidado com
Oficial Farma, porque eles fazem eh
campanhas de venda muito agressivas,
vendem um monte de coisa que deveria ter
receita e enfim, tome muito cuidado, tá?
Uso T3 10 microg e T4 50 mg para o
hipotiroidismo, mas sinto que acelera
meu coração e dá palpitações. Tem algo a
ver? Tem tudo a ver. tem tudo a ver.
Toma muito cuidado. Tem que ver os seus
números.
Pode ser que você esteja tomando uma
dose excessiva. Os sintomas de
palputação e aceleração
eh quase certo que estão relacionados ao
excesso de hormônios circulantes.
O que mais acontece, tá, é eu exagero na
dose do T3. Eu geralmente não passo 10
mg de T3 de uma vez. Eu passo no máximo
5 microg por dose e peço pra pessoa eh
dividir em duas doses, tá? Uma dose de
manhã, por exemplo, em jejum, outra dose
meia hora antes do almoço ou se a pessoa
quiser tomar à noite. Eu não gosto muito
de dar noite porque já que teve alguns
casos que a pessoa ficou agitada e não
conseguiu dormir, apesar de não ser
muito comum, tá? Então tomo muito
cuidado. Eu não tomaria 10 microg T3 de
uma vez.
Eu tomaria no máximo 5 microg por vez.
OK?
Isso na verdade é uma grande crítica que
os endocrinologistas ortodoxos têm em
relação ao T3. Às vezes você tem umas
respostas meio,
ah, como se diz,
algumas respostas paradoxais ou algumas
respostas não previsíveis com T3,
especialmente doses mais altas. Por isso
que eles criticam muito. Eu
particularmente não uso do acima de
cinco.
E tem que tomar cuidado porque se você
tiver uma tendência à arritmia cardíaca,
eh, essa palpitação pode gerar uma
situação de estabilidade
elétrica no coração e, em casos dos
extremos, até o infarto, tá? Então, tome
muito cuidado, baixa essa dose desse T3.
Aí o T4 ele tem uma meia vida muito mais
longa, ele é bem mais seguro,
por conta disso, então ele vai ser
metabolizado muito mais lento, tá?
Então tem que dosar o teu TSH, tem que
dosar o T3 L, T4 L para ver se não tá em
acesso essa dose que você tá utilizando
aí.
Bem, vamos pra próxima.
Doutor, tenho titrofia de fuxo.
Observei relatos no grupo falando do MSO
com a finalidade de regeneração. Pode
falar sobre isso? Tenho muito receio de
usar qualquer coisa diferente e piorar
um problema já grave, no meu entender.
Gratidão.
O seu receio é muito sábio, OK? e não
faça coisas precipitadas.
Não temos muita evidência sobre o DMSO
em questão aí de regeneração de nervos
periféricos
paraa distrofia de fucos, que é uma
doença rara.
Nós sabemos sim que o DMSO tem
propriedades antiinflamatórias,
pode inibir a neovascularização corneal,
OK?
Porém, a distrofia de fluxo é uma
degeneração específica das células
endoteliais da córnea.
Não é um problema de inflamação ou
neovascularização. OK?
Então, os tratamentos que t comprovação
nesses estágios iniciais são os colírios
hipertônicos para reduzir o edema.
E quando tem progressão da doença, o
transplante endotelial é a única
solução. Então, faça seu acompanhamento
regular com o seu oftalmologista, use os
colidos que ele recomenda.
Eh, pode usar o DMSO como tratamento de
suporte, tá? Não como uma cura garantida
ou algo assim.
E pode variar resposta de pessoa para
pessoa. Sempre lembrar disso, tá?
Caldo de osso. Ossos do fêm do boi vai
cozinhando e a cabeça do fêmeo se
deslocam as partes. Essas partes ficam
muito mole na panela de pressão
elétrica. Pode raspar essas partes moles
e deixar se misturar no caldo.
Não vejo problema nenhum nisso não, viu,
Maria Helena?
Essas partes moles que você tá
descrevendo, que se desprendem, é
exatamente o que você quer manter no
caldo, que é medula óssea
e também parte da cartilagem do fêmor,
que vai ter os nutrientes que você quer,
que é colágeno,
eh, gelatina, vários aminoassoltos, como
é glicina e prolina, que fazem parte do
colágeno.
Então, raspar essas partes e deixá-las
se misturarem no caldo, vai sim aumentar
a concentração de nutrientes,
especialmente o colágeno tipo um, que é
importante para ossos, articulações,
pele e saúde vascular.
Então, panela de pressão elétrica é
apropriada para isso. Acelera o processo
de extração dos nutrientes. Deixa
cozinhar bastante tempo. Quanto mais
tempo for é melhor.
E quando esfriar você vai notar que o
caldo vai virar gelatina, né? Que é um
sinal de que você extraiam bem o
colágeno, tá? Então não desperdice nada
dessas partes moles porque são muito
interessantes em termos nutricionais.
Se uma pessoa tomar duas cápulas do 3
Meg DHA de manhã e à noite tomar mais
duas pode dar excesso
ou é até melhor e diminuindo o tempo de
reposição, sendo objetivo acelerar a
reposição. Se tomar ômega-3 depois toma
café ou outra substância corta ou
diminui o efeito do ômega-3.
Então, manter-se hidratado antes de
dormir pode impedir ou diminuir sequelas
de infarto e AVC. A, nossa, tem várias
perguntas aqui misturadas, né? E é bom
evitar isso, pessoal. Ficar meio confuso
de responder, tá? A dieta cetogênica
três semanas antes de um infarto e AVC
pode ir desentupindo as artérias e
evitar.
A dieta cetogênica por si só
desentope as artérias do coração e da
cabeça. Vamos lá, começando pela dosagem
do ômega-3,
o mega DHA que você mencionou tem 1500
de DHA, 1500 mg e 300 mg de EPA por
cápsula.
quatro cápsulas totalizariam 7200 mg de
3, o que ultrapassaria o limite seguro
por conta de poder causar um efeito
anticoagulante, OK?
Então poderia aumentar o risco de
sangramentos. Então não é necessário e
nem recomendado, além de ficar caro.
Então tome três cápsulas diárias
se você quiser trabalhar dentro do
limite superior.
Não faz sentido você tomar uma dose alta
temporariamente para tipo fazer uma
carga. É mais interessante preferir você
manter a dosagem adequada
consistentemente porque você aumentar a
dose para tentar fazer uma carga rápida.
O café não diminui a absorção de
ômega-3, tá? Porque como gordura ômega-3
ela acaba sendo autossuficiente aí na na
absorção.
Hidratação antes de dormir, ã, não
exatamente antes de dormir. Hidratação
em geral vai ter uma relação na
prevenção de sequela de infarto ou AVC,
hidratação em geral, não hidratação
especificamente antes de dormir.
A diacetogênica, sim, vai ajudar a
reduzir o LDL oxidado
e vai reduzir a quantidade de partículas
pequenas e densas de LDL,
mas por si só não vai desentupir
artérias, tá? Para isso aí eu
recomendaria você fazer uso daquela
fórmula com natoquinar piquinogenol que
vai depois de 2 a 3 anos ter esse
efeito, OK? para placas moles.
Deixa eu ver se eu respondi tudo aqui.
Acho que sim, né?
Ah, então a dieta cetogênica sozinha não
vai desentupir a artéria, tá bom? Ela
vai prevenir a piora. E para desentupir,
você teria que estar utilizando umas
fórmulas aí que tem efeito eh de
desfazer a,
né, coágulos ou desfazer placas de
fibrina, como eu falei.
Dr. Alão, médico da minha irmã, passou
vitamina D3 15.000 unidades sem K2. É,
acima de 10.000 é recomendado que se use
o K2 junto, tá? Eu achei um absurdo. É,
não necessariamente, tá? É um absurdo,
mas é recomendado que se use o K2 junto.
Ela está com vitamina D3 de 23 muito
baixo. Faz sentido usar T3 CH2? Por
tempos curtos faz sentido. Agora para
tempos, para uma reposição mais longa aí
não faria isso não, tá? Eu faria junto
com a K2.
Porque o que pode acontecer é o
seguinte, pessoal tá com a vitamina D lá
embaixo, você repõe com a dose alta
temporária de vitamina D, essa pessoa
pode ser que de uma hora para outra
começa a absorver mais cálcio por conta
da
vitamina D e se ela tiver um risco maior
cardiovascular, esse cálcio pode parar
no lugar errado. vez ele pro osso, ele
pode parar na parede da artéria, que é o
justamente essa função da K2, que é o
GPS que direciona o cálcio para o osso.
Então, sem H2, o cálcio pode acabar
calcificando parede de artéria ou rim ou
mesmo tecidos moles. Pode gerar espaço
musculares,
pode até formar pedra no zin se a pessoa
tiver tendência.
Então, a relação que a gente usa para
cada 10.000 unidades de D3, 100 microg.
Então, para 15.000 seria 150 mg de K2,
tá? Então, peça para ela começar a usar
o K2, especialmente se essa ideia é
utilizar essa vitamina D3 por um período
mais prolongado, tá?
Lembrando que D3 e K2 são vitaminas
lipossolúveis e vão ser melhor
absorvidas se a pessoa ingerir junto com
gordura. OK?
E conversa com calma, né? Com o Tato,
com o médico com médico que prescreveu.
Não não chega acusando, ah, você
esqueceu o K2, não sei o que lá. Você
conversa com calma e que a pessoa
certamente, a maioria dos médicos ou
médicas não se oporiam a colocar K2 na
receita. Mas também você não precisa
esperar, você pode simplesmente começar
a tomar K2 por conta, tá bom? É muito
segura a K2.
Qual é o melhor horário para se tomar
blend de magnésio? De malato? Deve ser
de malato, né? Bisglicinato, treonato,
vitamina C, complexo B, ô3, D3, zinco,
cobre e cálcio.
Ã, tá. Tem bastante coisa misturada
aqui. A, o magnésio não tem o melhor
horário não. Você pode tomar qualquer
horário, à noite vai ajudar no sono, tá?
Agora é interessante usar o complexo B
de manhã com a primeira refeição,
porque o complexo B ajuda no metabolismo
energético, então de manhã você um bom
horário para tomar.
A vitamina C zinco, você pode tomar, por
exemplo, logo em seguida o complexo B.
Pode também utilizar
eh a tomada junto com alimento ácido,
porque a vitamina C potencializa
a absorção de ferro e também do zinco,
tá bom?
Você pode deixar, por exemplo, o ômega-3
pro almoço ou pro final da tarde, junto
com uma refeição que tenha gordura
saudável e junto com a vitamina D3.
E se você quiser, você pode concentrar
todo o magnésio à noite antes de dormir,
apesar disso não ser obrigatório, tá?
Agora, o importante é tentar, se
possível, separar os minerais, tá? Se
você puder separar o zinco e o cobre,
e o zinco e o cobre do cálcio, é
interessante, a não ser que sejam formas
queeladas, né? formas de minerais
ligadas aos aminoácidos.
Então, tenta tomar os três minerais em
orário diferente. Se não for possível,
aí você separa o cálcio do zí do cobre,
ok?
O cálcio, por exemplo, você pode digerir
antes de dormir, tipo uma meia hora após
o magnésio. Isso isso pode ser uma uma
estratégia.
Ou pode até combinar o cálcio com
magnésio à noite também, tá? Isso é
possível.
Agora tem que ver o seguinte, tá? Não é
obrigatório, tá? O pessoal confunde
muito, que eu já falei isso em vídeos, o
pessoal pensa que toda vez que toma
cobra tem que tomar zinco, toda vez que
toma zinco, tem que tomar cobre. Não é
bem assim. Existe uma proporção que é de
um para 15 ou um para 20 entre o cobre e
o magnéo, desculpa, entre o cobre e o
zinco. Eh, mas não quer dizer que todo
mundo tem que tomar os dois juntos. Às
vezes você tem uma pessoa que tá com
zinco alto e o cobre baixo. Aí faz
sentido você dar cobre para compensar o
zinco alto e para aumentar o cobre. Ou
vice-versa. O cobre tá alto e o zinco tá
baixo, você dá zinco sem dar o cobre. Tá
bom?
Pode ter alguma interação não desejada
entre os suplementos magnésio, dimalato,
bisglicinato, tronato, vitamina C,
complexo B, ômega3, zinco, cobre,
cálcio, cistanche.
Não entendi o que que é cistanche.
Progesterona micronizada.
Tá dando toda a lista que toma aqui.
Triodotironina, oxandrolona, vitamina A
e cólicaciferol.
Tá tomando tudo junto, é isso?
Tá na mesma fórmula, provavelmente, né?
Por isso tá perguntando isso daí, né?
Bem, temos aí uma relação competitiva
entre o coab e o zinco. Se tiver em
queelado, isso daí diminui bastante o
problema, tá? Mas o ideal mesmo seria
separar os horários.
O magnésio e o cálcio podem competir em
certos momentos ou circunstâncias. Se
tiverem queelado também diminui
bastante.
A vitamina A tem que tomar um certo
cuidado com ela, tá? Especialmente
algumas formas de vitamina A, que é uma
das poucas vitaminas que podem intoxicar
a vitamina A e a vitamina E. Dependendo
da forma que você toma e pro tempo que
você toma. Se você não tiver medindo no
sangue, pode acontecer da vitamina A e
da vitamina E intoxicar, OK?
Então, de modo geral, dá para associar
tudo isso daí, pensando só que os
minerais podem diminuir um pouco a
absorção pela competição.
Os hormônios que você mencionou aí, eh,
eu não juntaria progesterona com a com
T3, né, com o triodo tironina, que pode
absorção do T3, eu deixaria separado.
tomaria, por exemplo, T3 em jejum e
esperaria meia hora para tomar os
outros.
Os hormônios em geral que você tá
comentando aí, não tem interações
importantes com os outros suplementos.
Toma muito cuidado com o xandrolona.
Oxandrolona é um é um anolizante, né?
Não é uma coisa que você pode tomar por
tempo prolongado, sem causar problemas.
Androlona, inclusive pode aumentar o
risco cardiovascular e o risco de
problemas no fígado.
Então, tome muito pouco tempo.
Oxandrolona eh talvez pra maioria das
pessoas não vale a pena ficar tomando
isso daí, porque geralmente é utilizado
para fins estéticos, né, para perder
gordura e ganhar massa muscular em
mulher, principalmente. Eu evitaria de
utilizar, tá? Ou se for utilizar, usar
no máximo seis semanas seguidas,
OK?
Agora stanche, sinceramente, eu não sei
o que que é, não conheço.
Depois eu vou até dar uma olhada. Deixa
eu olhar isso até agora que eu fiquei
curioso agora.
Não conheço esse produto.
Ah, é uma planta parasita do deserto,
conhecida como ginzou
a erva do dragão.
Eu não conheço, eu nunca usei esse
produto.
é comercializada como suplemento para
vitalidade, libido, resistência física
cognitiva.
Eu já tinha visto sobre o sangue do
dragão, agora essa daí erva do dragão,
eu não conhecia não.
Depois eu vou dar uma estudada com mais
calma isso daí.
E agora ouvindo esse nome,
eu acho que eu já vi isso antes, mas não
não prestei muita atenção nisso.
Na live do dia 9 de janeiro, você
comentou que apareceram alguns estudos
dizendo que consumir suplemento
melatonina durante o dia afeta o ciclo
circadiano.
A live do dia 11, você comentou que se
for consumir 200 mg ou 300 do suplemento
CTP, tem que dividir ao longo do dia.
Minha dúvida, ao consumir 200 ou 300 mg
de CTP dividido ao longo do dia, isso
vai afetar o ciclo? Não. Eh, porque
assim, melatonina é diferente de 5 ATP,
tá? CTP é cidróxid triptofano.
Eh, se você toma durante o dia,
geralmente vira serotonina, mas não é
garantido. Se você toma à noite,
geralmente vira melatonina, tá? A
questão é de você não tomar uma dose
grande de uma vez só de 5 HTT, porque
pode ter o risco teórico você fazer uma
síndrome de serotoninérgica. Essa que é
a questão, tá? Não sei se você entendeu
o que eu expliquei.
A questão da melatonina, eu acho que
ainda vai dar muito pano paraa manga,
tá? Tá uma briga aí, uns defendendo,
outros dizendo que melatonina dá
problema. É um é uma questão confusa
ainda, né?
Tá. Então, recapitulando, o CTP, quando
você toma de manhã, geralmente ele vira
serotonina
e essa conversão é gradual
e a serotonina vai ter outras funções,
né, e modulação de humor
e não vai ser necessariamente uma
precursora de melatonina porque vai ter
luz, porque a conversão da melatonina e
do da serotonina e melatonina corre
quando tem ausência de luz, tá? Então
essa que é a questão aí.
E tem outra questão também que se você
tomar dose alta de 5 HTP, você pode ter
náusea, tá?
É um efeito colateral comum do 5 KTP.
Ficou claro, Eliseu? Eliseu que mandou a
pergunta. Eh, ficou claro, Eliseu?
Depois eu vejo a tua resposta aí ao
vivo, tá?
Paraa próxima pergunta.
Qual é a quantidade mínima de proteína
que devemos consumir por dia? Eh, o
mínimo mínimo recomendado é 0,8 g de
proteína por kilo de peso corporal. OK?
Isso daí, lembrando que 1 kg de carne
não quer dizer que é 1 kg de proteína.
Você tem que fazer as contas. Tem
aplicativos que fazem esses essas contas
aí de macros. O mais conhecido é o
cronômeter, tá? Mas tem vários outros.
Então, pensando no mínimo, uma pessoa de
70 kg precisaria consumir pelo menos 70,
desculpa, uma pessoa de 70 kg precisaria
consumir pelo menos 56 g de áreas de
proteína, tá?
Isso é uma recomendação para indivíduos
adultos sedentários, tá?
Isso é o mínimo para prevenir
deficiência. Se você pratica atividade
física especialmente regular, aí você
pode aumentar isso para de 1,2 a 2 g por
kg, tá?
Isso vai depender da intensidade do
treinamento e dos seus objetivos.
E o mais interessante é você distribuir
a ingestão ao longo do dia. Pelo menos
três refeições diárias com proteínas,
café da manhã, almoço e jantar. OK?
Porque o corpo não armazena. E tinha
aquela história que você tinha que tá
ingerindo meia hora antes do treino.
Isso daí já meio que caiu parcialmente
por terra, tá? Não é obrigatório você
ingerir a proteína meia hora antes do
treino ou meia hora depois do treino. É
o mais importante distribuir ao longo do
dia.
Qual é o percentual de proteína em 100 g
de carne bovina, suína, frango e peixe?
Vamos lá. A carne bovina, antes eu tinha
falado isso numa outra live, se eu não
me engano, que era metade, né, do peso
era proteína, mas se eu falei isso, não
lembro agora, tá errado, tá? A carne
bovina tem entre 20 a 28 g de proteína
por 100 g, OK? Então dá 20 a 28%,
OK?
20 a 28%. Então para você não ter
dificuldade de lembrar, vamos colocar a
média aí de 25%, tá? Então, um bife,
pensa que um bife o peso dele, 25% do
peso vai ser proteína. Lógico, isso
varia conforme o corte e gordura, mas
vamos o grau de gordura, mas vamos
simplificar isso aí. A carne suína, se
for uma carne suína magra, é bem
parecida, de 20 a 22% de de proteína.
E se for uma peça gordurosa, vai ser
17%.
O frango, se for sem pele, é uma das
opções mais proteicas em termos
percentuais. Então vai para 28 a 30 g
por 100 g, ou seja, 28 a 30%.
Agora, se você comer o frango com pele,
pode baixar para 20%, OK?
O peixe vai variar de acordo com a
espécie, OK? Eh, o teor de proteína, mas
você pode também tá calculando mais ou
menos 20%.
OK? Então, carne vermelha, boi 25%,
frango por volta de 30%.
E peixe você pode calcular 20% também.
OK?
E a carne de porco, como eu já falei, se
foi carne magra, é bem parecido com a
carne vermelha, vai dar de 20 a 22%.
O próximo,
em um vídeo seu de um ano atrás, o
senhor recomendou que o DMSO deve ser
acondicionado em frasco de vidro, pois
ele dissolve plástico. Sim, existe essa
história sim. Seguindo essa linha de
pensamento, ele não poderia ter ação
sobre o microplástico contido no corpo
humano? Olha, isso aí é uma suposição,
pode até fazer sentido, mas
extrapulações teóricas geralmente não
são reais, porque a gente não tem
evidência
na literatura sobre isso. OK?
Pensa o seguinte, o o a condição do
organismo vivo é muito diferente de um
ambiente
externo, tá? Porque
a o corpo humano tem milhares de
substâncias dissolvidas junto. E
o ambiente não é um ambiente líquido, é
um ambiente gel, né, geralmente no
organismo.
Então tem também a questão do pH, né, o
pH, cada
compartimento do organismo um pH
diferente, tá? vai ter interação de
milhares de substâncias, de proteínas,
de gordura, de temperatura corporal
variada de acordo com o fluido,
também ação do sistema imune, um monte
de coisa aí. É muito complexo da gente
analisar isso aí, tá? Que é muito
diferente com frasco de vidro.
E também não é sabido qual seria a
concentração efetiva de DMSO que poderia
dissolver um microplástico num ambiente
de tecido ou na circulação sanguínea.
Então, provavelmente a concentração de
DMSO
que seria necessária para dissolver
microplástico teria que ser bem alta e
passaria muito da quantidade segura, tá?
Isso é uma especulação que eu tô falando
aqui, OK?
A única,
aliás, o único tratamento que a
literatura internacional tem
proposto até o momento para
microplástico, seria uma uma fée
terapêutica, né, que é tipo uma
filturação do do sangue através de uma
máquina muito cara, tá? A fé ou plasma
fé, né, que chama isso daí.
O demencial poderia ajudar como
antiinflamatório antioxidante para
combater os efeitos indiretos aí do
microplástico. OK?
Então, como você não vai fazer plasma
fé, né, ou a fé, a única maneira que
você tem que se proteger contra
microplásticos é evitar o uso do
plástico máximo que você puder, ok?
Essa aqui tá repetida.
A Maria Helena mandou de novo
óleo de palma que geralmente faz parte
dos ingredientes do amenduim torrado. É
refinado.
Então eu já escutei essa história do Lai
Ribeiro, né, que ele diz que o óleo de
palma seria refinado. Eu me lembro disso
numa aula que eu tive lá na época da
pós.
Mas vamos falar do óleo de palma que tá
em pastas e manteigas de amuir torrado.
Geralmente nessa situação ele tá
totalmente hidrogenado. Esse óleo, tá?
Isso é péssimo, né?
Então, mas se for um óleo de palma que
tá sendo utilizado em cosméticos, aí com
certeza ele é refinado nessa
circunstância.
Para quem não sabe, hidrogenação é um
processo que transforma os óleos
líquidos em temperatura ambiente.
Aliás, o contrário, né? É hidrogenação é
um processo que pega gorduras sólidas em
temperatura ambiente e transforme óleos
líquidos para fins de indústria, OK?
Também para melhorar a textura de alguns
alimentos. Isso cria gorduras trans que
são péssimas pra saúde.
Então, evite o óleo de palma, tá?
O óleo de palma poderia ser colocado
junto aí com o óleo de de amuim, como
também assim como óleo de
algodão, soja e também e milho são os
óleos que são hidrogenados que não são
seguros, tá? Então óleo de palma pode
parecer muito parecido com óleo de coco,
mas não utilize, tá? Óleo de palma.
A não ser que você consiga exatamente o
óleo de palma comprovadamente não
refinado ou não hidrogenado,
ok?
E se você utilizar uma pasta de menuim,
usa o mais simples possível, sem açúcar,
apenas como ingredientes a meninuir em
sal, tá?
Não utilize o creme diminuir com açúcar.
Minha mãe irá confiando em Deus se
consultar com o senhor e posteriormente
meu pai e eu também. Muito obrigado pela
confiança. Gostaria de lhe pedir, se for
possível, a gentileza de informar quais
exames o senhor costuma solicitar para
pacientes sexo feminino
acima de 50 anos. É uma lista meio
grande, tá? Não tem necessidade de ficar
falando na live. Você pode entrar em
contato com a secretária e pegar a lista
com ela, tá?
Eh, não tem problema nenhum.
Tem diabetes controlado. Possamos
verificar antecipadamente a
disponibilidade desses exames em nossa
cidade. Não, não, não são exames super
especiais, não. Você vai ter esses
exames com certeza disponíveis na cidade
e se não tiver com certeza o laboratório
vai saber para onde mandar, tá? Porque
todos os laboratórios pequenos têm essa
comunicação com laboratórios maiores
para poder mandar para fora.
É uma lista de exames padrãos, sim.
Obviamente que cada caso é um caso, mas
a gente casos mais complexos, por
exemplo, peço ácidos orgânicos urinários
ou peço coprológico funcional do
compromax ou peço exames especiais de
acordo com caso. Tá bom? Agora, essa
lista de exame de laboratório que o
plano cobre, essa lista é padrão, sim.
Só vai variar de homem para mulher. E
eu praticamente não atendo criança,
então é a mesma lista para homem e a
mesma lista para mulher nessa faixa de
idade de adulto. Tá bom?
Ah, entrei em contato com a sua
secretária que me informou que essas
orientações normalmente são dadas. É
porque a Raiana é meio teimosa com isso.
Eu já falei para ela que ela podia
passar
o pedido de exame antes. É porque tem
alguns pacientes que estão pegando o
pedido de exames e não tão e não estão
depois passando em consulta, tá? Tipo, a
pessoa joga o Migué que quer passar em
consulta e depois só pega o pedido para
fazer exame e nunca passa. Deve ser por
isso que ela tá fazendo isso, tá?
Ah, no entanto, como precisamos nos
organizar com antecedência, resolvi
fazer esse contato, tá?
Eh,
eu vou conversar com a Raine, mas assim,
é por isso que ela tá fazendo essa
maneira, tá? Teve vários casos de
pessoas que pegaram o pedido de exame e
depois não passaram consulta, só queriam
saber do pedido de exame mesmo, né? Isso
não é muito correto, porque a pessoa vai
pegar o o resultado, não vai saber
interpretar, vai gerar ansiedade ou
então vai pegar esse resultado e vai
mostrar para um médico que talvez nem
saiba interpretar, entendeu?
É possível, com base na experiência
clínica e na análise de exames de
sangue, identificar se uma pessoa, homem
ou mulher, com diabetes controlado,
apresenta risco leve, moderado ou
elevado de infarto EVC? Sim, tem
algoritmos, né? tem contas matemáticas
que se pode fazer para, lógico que isso
daí não é exato, né? É uma aproximação,
mas existe algoritmos para verificar
isso. E de acordo com o nível de risco,
é possível indicar suplementos que é
oscilem? Lógico? Lógico que sim. A
resposta é sim e sim. Tá.
Em alguns casos, a gente pode pedir LDL
oxidado, pode pedir a pro lipoproteína
A1 e B, a relação entre os dois.
Se a pessoa tiver acesso, pode até fazer
o lipidograma avançado para contar o
número de partículas de LDL, né,
e do tamanho das partículas também.
Então existe toda essa situação, sim.
Você pode tá, existe algoritmos aí que
fazem essas contas aí,
tá? A gente trabalha bastante com
suplemento e trabalha aí também com
alguns fármacos em algumas situações,
né? Então, digamos que 80% do que eu
prescrevo é suplemento e 20% mais ou
menos é é medicamento bem indicado aí
com mínimo de risco possível.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta aqui.
Se peróxido de hidrogênio endovenoso
seria eficaz para tratamento do epistem
bar?
É, o peróxido hidrogênio é um agente
oxidante, tá? Então, a gente usa muito
ele para infecções,
eh, pode ser utilizado para câncer, para
aumentar o estresse oxidativo das
células tumorais e tem ação também
antiviral, tá?
Tem ação tiveral também, tem ação também
imunomoduladora
ajuda do sistema imune.
Infelizmente é uma coisa que não
desperta o interesse da Big Farma, né?
Porque não tem patente, então não tem
grandes estudos mostrando isso, mas
existe sim evidências que tm ação de
viral.
Tem também uma ação direta de aumentar a
oxigenação tecidual, OK?
Agora, não utilize peróxido de
hidrogênio do venoso isoladamente. Você
pode estar utilizando ele junto com
outras estratégias, né? Melhorar o
sistema imune com zinc com com vitamina
D, com magnésio, complexo B,
ã, cortar os alimentos inflamatórios.
Você pode utilizar também o ozônio em
conjunto com peróxido hidrogênio no
venoso, fazer uso do ozônio ou com alto
emo maior ou ozônio retal. Você pode
também alternar o peróxido de hidrogênio
com azul de metileno também que ajuda.
Tem ação anti viral também, tá? Azul de
metileno endovenoso, certo?
Então todas as estratégias estão válidas
aí.
Suplementação de melatonina.
Eh, 5 mg é seguro tomar em uso contínuo
ou é melhor em ciclos?
Essa dose, né, para quem é fã da
melatonina, ela é considerada segura,
sim, mas existe alguma literatura
falando que essa dose é excessiva,
que poderia causar problemas aí, tá? Eh,
é lógico que a gente usa a melonina em
doses altas para câncer, tá? Tá? Então
é, cada caso é um caso.
Eu não usaria essa dose o tempo todo. Eu
usaria uma dose mais baixa entre 0,5 a 2
mg, tá? Mas tem muita gente que pode
tomar 5 mg sem nenhum problema.
Agora, se você não está fazendo com
acompanhamento médico, eu não faria uso
contínuo, tá?
Aí eu usaria por dois a três meses
consecutivos
e faria um uma pausa de um a dois meses
fazendo essa alternância aí.
Então a melatonina vai ser mais
eficiente para uso isolado para jet leg,
né? Você faz um voo e tá em jet, aí você
pode utilizar melatonina.
Agora, na minha experiência, uso isolado
para quem não consegue dormir geralmente
é ineficaz, tá? É muito difícil só com
melatonina você resolver essa questão de
insônia, porque a insônia é
multifatorial e tá muito ligada a
estresse e a melatonina sozinha
geralmente não resolve.
Doutor, o que que o senhor acha de quem
tem intolerância a estamina,
fazer a dieta carnívora?
Depende, tá? Ela pode ser uma boa
ferramenta, mas lembrando que tem
algumas formas de carne que podem sim
liberar estamina. Se for uma carne
maturada, por exemplo, uma carne que foi
fermentada de alguma maneira, vai
liberar bastante estamina. Então, não é
que toda a carne tá liberada para quem
tem toleramina. OK? Outra coisa também
que geralmente quem fazeta carnívora não
come só carne o vícera, acaba comendo
também queijo, laticínio, que são a
alimentos ricos em estamina, OK?
Especialmente os queijos envelhecidos.
Além da carne que eu falei maturada ter
bastante tamamina, carne latada, carne
processada, carne processada eu não
indico para ninguém, tá? muito menos
enlatada, mas tô aqui comentando que
essas carnes também têm altos níveis de
estamina,
OK? Carne defumada também, eh, tudo isso
tem que ser levado em consideração.
Agora, se você comer só carne fresca, só
víceera fresca também,
eh, e eliminar os laticínios,
tá? Aí sim você estaria fazendo uma
dieta carnívora baixa em estamina.
Então, mais importante para uma dieta
baixa estamina é alimentos frescos, o
mínimo possível de alimento guardado por
algum tempo.
OK? Então, pode ser pensado se você
tiver essa possibilidade aí.
Agora, essa carne foi congelada,
OK? Adequadamente, você descongela e
come rápido, aí ela não vai ter problema
com estamina, não, tá?
É verdade que o café aumenta a insulina?
Quem tem insulina alta de e parar deve
parar, né,
de tomar eh ou duas xícaras deve ser,
deve ser que tomo duas xícaras pela
manhã, né? Bem, aí a resposta é
interessante, né? O café ele não chega a
aumentar a insulina de uma maneira
direta, mas aumenta de maneira indireta,
porque quando você tomar café,
geralmente tem um estímulo do cortisol e
o cortisol aumenta a glicose, ok? Então
a cafeína
aumenta o cortisol e aumenta a
adrenalina, que por sua vez pode
aumentar a glicose, mas é um efeito leve
e é um efeito indireto. Por sua vez, né?
Por outro lado, os componentes do café,
os antioxidantes, polifenóis, vão
melhorar a sensibilidade insulina ao
longo do tempo. Então, o efeito final do
café acaba sendo
eh de reduzir a resistência insulínica e
não aumentar, mas se você tomar sem
açúcar, tá? Tomando com açúcar é outra
história.
Então, para quem tem insulina alta,
tomar café não é necessariamente
prejudicial e pode ajudar na
sensibilidade
a insulina. especialmente o café
descafeinado, tá? Que teve um efeito
melhor aí na questão da melhor da
sensibilidade à insulina.
OK?
Então, tem alguns estudos que mostram
que tomar café de manhã,
eh, dependendo do horário, pode ser
interessante. Então, se você tomar
depois das 9 horas,
olha só que interessante, depois das 9
horas pode sim aumentar o risco de
diabetes tipo 2. Se você toma
incomparado a tomar antes das 8. Então,
é melhor tomar antes das 8 do que depois
das 9, tá?
E mas caso você tome depois das 9, aí
você tome depois de uma refeição
completa para modular melhor a resposta
glicêmica, tá?
Bem, eu acho que terminou, né? Ah, não
tem mais duas aqui. O pessoal fez as
perguntas durante
a própria live. Pente com ma hálito de
origem estomacal ou intestinal ou dor de
fossa cétrica que geralmente está
associado à produção de sulfeto de
hidrogênio.
Esse tipo de cheiro é típico de disbiose
intestinal ou cibo. Resulta da
degradação de aminoácido sulfurado,
cisteína, meteolina, produzido por
bactérias como dooffu vibrio, bilófila,
zórfia e alguma espécie de clustrídio.
Qual a sua sugestão de tratamento?
É uma forma de esbiose, né? Quando você
faz o teste de gases espirados, tem três
tipos de gases que são analisados. Se
bem que no Brasil até pouquíssimo tempo
só tinha a dosagem hidrogênio, mas se
você quer fazer completo, você tem que
dosar hidrogênio, sulfeto de hidrogênio
e metano, OK? Então, se tiver aumento de
sulfeto de hidrogênio, que sabe,
pessoal, tem uma disbiose,
aí tem que tratar a disbiose, tá?
Geralmente você começa com o uso de
antibióticos, que pode ser natural ou
não, tá? Então dependendo do tipo de
cibo, você pode ter que utilizar
neomicina,
usar rifaximina ou pode usar
metronidrazol,
ou pode usar os naturais, né, os
antibióticos naturais. Aí depois de três
semanas a a seis semanas de tratamento
com antibióticos naturais ou não, aí
você passa para uso de eh
pré prébióticos e probióticos e também
pós-bióticos,
OK? Lembrando que essas essas disbioses
aí tem muita recidiva, muita recidiva.
Então tomar muito cuidado fazer o
tratamento antibiótico
natural, né? Eh, muitas vezes eu passo
até por 90 dias tratamento com
antibiótico natural
para poder reduzir, né, essa
proliferação bacteriana, intestino
delgado e depois mudar totalmente a
alimentação da pessoa, mudar os hábitos,
gerenciar o estress, gerenciar o sono e
para não voltar, tá certo? Essa questão
aí do
do cibo, tá?
Ahã.
Então isso daí eu eu imagino que você
tenha tenha feito aí um exame de gás
espirados, né? Um exame de cibo e deve
ter feito o exame de microbioma, né? Eu
não vou dar um tratamento super
específico, tá? Porque não esse não é o
objetivo da nossa live aqui. Isso aí é
quase que você tá tentando cavar uma
consulta, né? Eu entendo, né, a tua
necessidade, mas eu não posso fazer isso
em lives, tá?
Só tô te dando uma orientação geral
agora. Importante você fazer um
agendamento ou comigo ou com a Dra.
Denise de Carvalho, que eu não sei se
ela tá pegando paciente novos, ou até o
Dr. Cristiano Rud, que é um excelente
gasto funcional também. Tem outras
pessoas também, tem a doutora,
caramba, já eu me esqueci o nome dela.
Deixa eu olhar aqui.
Deixa eu ver se eu acho aqui na meus
contatos.
É, tô achando aqui fácil. Mas tem uma
doutora que é muito boa também, que tá
sempre nos curso lemos.
Ver se eu consigo achar aqui no outro.
Pera aí.
Deu um branco o nome dela. Lívia Lívia
Guimarães. Então seria a Denise
Carvalho, o Cristiano Rud, a Lívia
Guimarães ou até mesmo comigo, tá bom?
Para você pegar uma conduta mais
específica.
Caminhada rápida. Que canção?
Cansão as pernas diferentes seus
defeitos da caminhada leve.
O canção eu não entendi, tá? Mas vamos
lá. Em termo de saúde cardiovascular, os
exercícios do tipo hit são melhores do
que uma caminhada num ritmo só. Então,
se você puder alternar, por exemplo, faz
uma caminhada leve, 5 km/h,
aí sobre para uma corrida leve, 9 km/h,
aí se você tiver preparo físico, vai
para 12 km/h por um período aí de 2
minutos, aí volta para 5 km/h. Então
fica alternando, tá? Isso é muito bom
pro tema cardiovascular, isso é mais do
que comprovado.
H, agora entre não fazer nada e fazer
uma caminhada leve, com certeza a
caminhada leve é muito melhor. Agora, se
você já tem preparo físico para isso,
você não tem problema ortopédico, não
tem problema no joelho, no quadril,
lugar nenhum, você pode fazer eh uma
alternância entre caminhada, corrida eh
leve, corrida mais intensa,
especialmente se for numa esteira, tá
bom? Agora, óbvio,
tem que ver se não tem problema no
joelho, no quadril, se não tem problema
de facite plantar, se não tem problema
de tornozelo, tá? Aí é outra história,
tá?
Não sei se era isso que tu queria saber,
porque ficou esquisito esse canção aqui,
né?
Bem, pessoal, deixa eu ver aqui.
H,
já temos uma hora de live. Eu já pedi
para vocês evitarem de jogar as as
perguntas aqui ao vivo, tá? Ah, deixa eu
ver se dá para responder mais algumas
aqui.
Ah, nessas gripes fósis que temos agora
em Portugal, usa zinco, usa vitamina C,
vitamina D,
pode usar o alho, também tem efeito
muito bom aí para evitar infecções
virais. Pode usar o própolis verde, tá?
Tá aqui a opinião da Elisa.
Excelente e abençoado 2026 para você e
paraa família também. Ana,
ah,
é possível manter cetose profunda.
Olha, a dieta cetogênica você pode fazer
carnívoro ou pode fazer não carnívoro ou
pode fazer
vegano. É possível a acetogênica de
todos os jeitos. É mais difícil você
entrar em cetose, tá?
Eh, se você comer muita proteína, você
não vai entrar em cetose. Só só lembrar
disso, tá?
É possível no mesmo dia você entrar em
cetose em determinado horário e no outro
horário você sair da cetose para poder
ganhar massa muscular, tá? Isso é uma
coisa difícil de coordenar, mas é
possível.
Não, não faça posição de trendurg só
para aumentar melhorar de gestão. Acho
ser bobagem.
Eu tô com dificuldade de ler aqui. Tá
muito pequenininho para mim. Deixa eu
fazer uma coisa aqui.
Ah, agora melhorou.
Pera aí, mas aqui,
OK.
Sim, você pode tomar antes dormir ou um
pouco antes, tanto faz. O Eliseu,
cadê as outras perguntas?
A indicação ginecologista integrativa
poderia ser a Dra. Marlene Siqueira, tá
bom?
D Marlene Siqueira.
Pera aí, tem tá com muita pergunta ao
vivo aqui.
Pode tanto fracionar, Eliseu, quanto
tomar antidormir, tanto faz, tá? O
magnésio
que eu saiba não, Eliseu.
Gente, evite de colocar as perguntas ao
vivo aqui. O documento serve para isso,
tá?
Evitem de fazer isso porque eu não vou
conseguir responder geralmente
e é mais difícil para eu acompanhar por
aqui.
Que bom, Antônio. Parabéns, viu?
Gente, tem muita muito comentário aqui.
Eu não vou conseguir acompanhar tudo
não. E estamos já passando de uma hora
de live.
Olha, é simples, tá? Eh, faça
fibromialgia é mais difícil, tá? Mais
fácil de plantar, é só você não correr.
Você pode fazer caminhada ou se tiver
pegando muito, é fácil de plantar. Aí
você faz hidroginástica até melhorar da
facite, faz a computa, usa a palmilha
até melhorar a facite, aí depois você
volta a fazer caminhada, tá?
Fibromialgia começa com exercício leve,
hidroginástica é uma boa alternativa ao
fazer pilates e com o tempo vai aumentar
a intensidade do exercício.
Tem vídeo sobre isso na parte fechada do
canal, tá? Só olhar lá.
Caramba, tem muita coisa ao vivo aqui.
Você pode marcar a consulta tanto
presencial quanto online, tá? Nós temos
as duas as duas modalidades. Fátima
[Música]
revertido. Acho muito difícil, viu,
Carlos? Eu acho que seria mais
prevenção, tá? Reversão. Isso aí quando
é uma pessoa só que fala, sempre tem que
ficar um pouco atento, tá? Que pode ser
uma pessoa tentando
simplesmente vender um produto, tá? Tome
cuidado com isso, com essas essas
afirmações assim, tá?
Isso aqui é individual, tá? Cada pessoa
vai ter uma dose, tá?
Escapou por um milagre do quê? Não sei.
Não peguei essa mensagem anterior.
Ah, deve ser essa pergunta aqui.
Sofri uma queda de uma escada de 10 m,
faturei várias costelas e também
perfurei o pulmão.
Se pode tomar o NAC tomando remédio para
neurisma? Geralmente pode. O NAC é um
aminoácido é muito seguro, tá? Mas
converse com o seu médico.
Obrigado pelo comentário, Roger.
A pergunta é feita no formulário que eu
divido toda semana, um dia antes da
live, tá? Então, não sei se você entrou
há pouco tempo, mas nós deixamos fixado
a pergunta um dia antes, no caso na
segunda-feira. Aí você pode entrar no
link do formulário Google e colocar tua
pergunta lá, tá bom?
Tem muita gente tem dificuldade essa com
essa coisa das mensagens fixadas, né? Eu
não sei porque vocês t acho que é o
pessoal que não tá muito acostumado com
WhatsApp, né?
Como fazer? Você entra em contato com o
telefone da secretária e e agenda, tá?
Eh, o telefone do atendimento
automático, começa a pular porque o
outro número não tenho memorizado. É 971
30 13 12, tá? 97130
13 12 971 30 13 12 código de área 11.
Tem várias alternativas para cân de
prósta. Tem vários protocolos que a
gente pode utilizar, tá?
Eu não vou entrar em detalhes agora pelo
tardar do horário, mas você pode deixar
a pergunta pra próxima live.
Lembrando pessoal, todas as lives ficam
gravadas, tá? Teve só uma live que eu
apaguei depois,
ah, mas depois eu eu subi de novo, tá?
Então sempre fica gravado, tá?
Eu entrei às 19:05 e não ouviu. Não
ouviu porque talvez você não colocou a
pergunta no formulário, mas se você
colocou é só você depois ver o vídeo
gravado, tá?
Ah,
tem muita coisa aqui. Não vou, gente.
Vou vou interromper, tá? Já tem mais de
uma hora aqui.
Doutor, você tem alguns vídeos antigos.
Isso aqui é uma pergunta ou é um
comentário?
Coceiras na região íntima, masculina, na
região também feminina. Não, eu acho que
eu nunca fiz vídeo sobre isso não, viu?
Que bom, Eliseu que ficou claro.
Magnésio ajuda para enxaqueca. Vitamina
B6 em altas doses você pode estar
experimentando, tá? Acima de 50 mg. Com
enzima Q10 também ajuda, mas tem gente
que não melhora nem usando tudo isso,
tá? É cada caso é um caso. Às vezes tem
que entrar com fármaco e ver o que que
tá disparando a tua enxaqueca. Tem que
ser uma consulta médica.
Aposta de edíos subiu para 8.000.
Médico deu anticoagulante. Comecei com
nac bromelaína, serrapeptase, natoquinas
e din agora 1800.
Tedin ah melhorou bastante, né? De 8.000
para 1800.
Tá meio confuso isso. Paciente recebeu
infusão, três antibióticos com médico.
Que que tem a ver o antibiótico com
dedímero? Aí não entendi. Porque
infecção pode aumentar o dedímo, pode
não ter nada a ver com o trombo, tá?
Então e a pergunta tá confusa aí.
Ah, é uma um questionamento válido, tá?
Ah, Maria Helena, mas a questão não é o
quantidade de dias que vive, não. Creio
que não é esse o ponto
principal.
Completando sua naturopata
automolecular. Tá, entendi.
Mas a pergunta ficou meio estranha. Você
não quer deixar uma pergunta no
formulário paraa semana que vem, não?
Melhor, viu, Na?
E tentar. Pessoal, você tem que revisar
a pergunta antes de mandar. Tem um
pessoal que manda tudo errado. Eh, não,
não é que eu sou sendo chato,
preciosista não, mas fica difícil de
entender e de responder da melhor
maneira. Então, pega a tua pergunta,
coloca lá no GPT, no chat GPT, pede para
pro chat PT reformular a pergunta,
entendeu? Porque às vezes vocês
escrevem, fica errado alguma coisa e não
consigo entender, tá?
Não, aí não tem jeito. A dexametazona tá
causando inchaço. Aí tem que fazer o
desmame da dexametazona para poder
desinchar, tá? Não vai ter nenhum
chazinho que vai resolver isso, não, tá?
É o o efeito colateral do cotcode é
muito intenso.
Ã, pessoal, eu vou encerrar aqui, tá? Tá
dando mais de uma hora. Tem muita coisa
aqui ainda, né? Tá aumentando muita
quantidade de membros na nossa
comunidade. Então eu vou estudar,
talvez, eu vou pensar com calma nisso
daí, porque inicialmente a gente fazia
uma live a cada 14 dias, né, de
perguntas. Depois eu passei para uma
live semanal, mas como tá aumentando o
número de pessoas,
tá bem? Eh, eu vou vou pensar em fazer
duas lives semanais, talvez, tá?
H,
e aí a gente volta a conversar sobre
esse assunto em breve, pessoal. Muito
obrigado. Feliz ano novo para vocês.
Tenham excelentes festas. Evitem de
mandar as perguntas ao vivo aqui, tá?
Porque eu perco controle, tá? Vamos usar
o formulário. Toda segunda-feira vocês
recebem o link do formulário. Para quem
é novo, tá? O link do formulário fica
fixado, tá?
Deixa eu ver se eu mostro para vocês
aqui.
Deixa eu dividir a tela aqui
só para para quem é novo entender.
Aqui, pessoal, ó. Tá vendo essa parte de
cima aqui, ó? Isso aqui fica os links
fixados.
Tá,
ó.
Tá bom. Só clicar aqui que ele vai, ele
alterna entre os links fixados, tá? No
celular é a mesma coisa.
Um abraço para vocês. Feliz ano novo.
Felicidade para vocês. Boas entradas.